Arthur's intelligence has come into its
own because we have had certain
demonstrations of its power for instance
the Google AI beating the best go player
in the world which had been a goal that
many people thought would not be
achieved for many decades and here it is
already we now we have examples of
Amazon echo Alexa Google people talking
to their machines and they were talking
back having a conversation and so it's
now suddenly easy for us to imagine how
the benefits of artificial intelligence
could kind of creep into the rest of our
lives and it's best I think to think of
these intelligences as smartness instead
of intelligence because we have a lot of
baggage with this idea of intelligence
if you think it leaves as artificial
smartness and everything getting smarter
I think we'll have a better idea of what
we're going to see so we don't have a
good English word for making smarter and
smarter and smarter Phi so I use the
word cognate I to mean making things
smarter and I'm suggesting that in fact
this is a very broad verb that will
apply to everything in our lives and
that basically anything that we have
already electrified made electronic
automatic we're now going to cognate I
so the first Industrial Revolution was
our large-scale switch from the
agricultural world where anything that
we made had to be done with natural
power muscle power human or animal
muscle power was the only way you can
make something the big switch was we
automated this we had electronic motors
gasoline steam engines we had automation
and we had artificial power that's what
powered the Industrial Revolution was we
could apply artificial power to
everything and we made a grid to deliver
that power to every farm and every home
in the country in the world and so
everything that had been done with
natural power was now being done with
artificial power so movement
transportation was amplified by this new
artificial power
so today when you get in your car and
turn a switch you're suddenly summoning
250 horses the equivalent of 202 horses
their natural power is made artificial
and is going to run your car down 60
miles an hour just with your turning of
the wrist so that's what the Industrial
Revolution was we took things that we
took natural muscle power and we
amplified them and we multiply that by
million times and that was made
everything that surrounds me right now
the surrounds the city all that came
from this artificial power we're going
to have a Second Industrial Revolution
where we take everything we've already
automated with Auto with synthetic
artificial power and now we're going to
add artificial intelligence on top we're
going to take that car that has 250
horses and now we're going to have 250
mines they're not human minds there's
their artificial minds but that's the
auto driven car and we're going to
multiply that power of adding this
natural excuse me this is artificial
smartness to everything and we're going
to have a second Industrial Revolution
where everything that we make has
previously electrified we're not going
to cognate I and that additional
smartness is going to unleash the power
that we have not even seen with the
Industrial Revolution the extent of this
transformation is very very profound and
that is what we're now in the dawn of
and we'll see in the next 20 years in a
very real way
[Music]